un término que vas a escuchar bastante
en tus vídeos de álgebra lineal y en tus
temas de álgebra lineal es el concepto
de combinación lineal y bueno en este
vídeo lo que quiero analizar es que es
una combinación lineal y una combinación
lineal es ni más ni menos que una
combinación lineal bueno realmente una
combinación lineal si lo vemos en un
aspecto mucho más formal es tomemos
varios vectores voy a tomar b1 b2 hasta
bn que son vectores pueden ser en r 2 en
rn voy a tomarlos en rn para definirlo
de una manera más general tomo en
lectores en rn y una combinación ideal
es tomarme una suma de estos vectores
así que escribir aquí una suma de estos
vectores es decir b1 b2 b3 b4 así hasta
bn todas estas sumas pero no son sólo
sumas además de ser sumar son sumas
escaladas es decir cada una estas sumas
está multiplicada por una constante
constante 1 por b 1 + la constante 2 por
b 2 hasta llegar al último sumando que
va a ser el ser humano
cnn hice uno hasta cn son puras
constantes es decir son números que
existen en los números reales y bueno sé
que tal vez todos en un poco abstracto
para ti pero me voy a tomar un ejemplo
voy a decir que el vector a y bueno
todos estos vectores deberían estar en
negritas o con una flecha encima pero
hay veces que es un poco pesado escribir
todas estas negritas y bueno ustedes
saben que son vectores así que me voy a
tomar el vector llamado 1 2 y también me
voy a tomar el vector b que va a ser el
0 3 y bueno ahora la pregunta es cuál es
una combinación lineal de a&b y bueno si
nos fijamos en la definición de arriba
es simple y sencillamente multiplicar
por una constante en este caso va a ser
la constante 0 y fui a multiplicar a b
por una constante que también va a ser
la constante 0 al final pueden ser
cualquier constantes entonces por qué no
tomar las 0 0 y si te das cuenta si
tomamos esta combinación lineal de 0 a 0
b nos dan el vector 0 es decir el vector
cuyas entradas o cuyas componentes son 0
y por eso voy a poner un 0 remarcado o
un 0 en negritas pero bueno la constante
aún es la constante 2
pueden ser cualquier número así que
vamos a tomar nosotras vamos a tomar los
tres o más y voy a poner un número
negativo menos dos veces b porque sé 1 y
c 2 pueden ser cualquier número en los
números reales y bueno cuánto me da esto
tres veces a es decir tres por una tres
menos dos veces b es menos dos por cero
cero y después abajo tengo tres veces 3
por 2 6 y menos dos veces b menos dos
por 36 menos 6 y esto me da pues 3 -0
que es 3 y 6 menos 6 que es 0 el vector
30 y aquí está les presento a otra
combinación lineal de ahí ve y si
seguimos con esta definición podemos
tomar cualquier segundo igual que irse 2
para hacer una combinación lineal puedo
cambiar este número 3 y menos 2 por
cualquier otro número que se me ocurra o
inclusive poner otro vector voy a poner
al vector sé que es el 72 sí nosotros a
esto le sumamos 8 veces también nos da
una combinación lineal pero en esta
ocasión de los vectores a b y c pues
sigue cumpliendo nuestra definición y
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
se llama combinación
porque no solamente combinación y la
respuesta es que aquí no tenemos en
ningún vector x otro vector es decir
solamente tenemos suma de vectores no
tenemos suma de vectores raros como por
ejemplo un vector elevado al cuadrado y
aunque yo sé que todavía no sabes qué es
un vector elevado al cuadrado esto no
cumpliría la definición de una
combinación lineal por eso necesitamos
tener solamente constantes con números
reales multiplicados por los vectores y
después tomar la suma de estos y eso es
lo que se le conoce como una combinación
lineal pero bueno también seguramente te
estás preguntando cómo se ve una
combinación lineal en el plano
cartesiano por lo tanto ahorita me voy a
deshacer de todo esto voy a tachar hace
no quiero pensar ahorita un poco en self
porque quiero trabajar solamente con la
combinación lineal de dos vectores de
dos vectores en r2 que en este caso van
a ser los vectores a ive y la pregunta
es qué va a pasar si los multiplicamos
por una constante y los sumamos así que
tenemos hace y recuerda que puede ser en
r2 o en cualquier espacio donde puedan
vivir vectores y bueno ya tengo hace y
no voy a explicar en qué pasaba con tres
veces a menos dos veces b
esto me da el 30 así que vamos a
dibujarlo en el plan cats ya no para ver
que me sale de tener tres veces y tres
veces para esto lo primero que voy a
hacer es fijarme en ahí voy a dibujar en
el plan cartesiano en posición estándar
a es el vector 12 entonces caminamos uno
a la derecha y dos hacia arriba déjame
ponerlo aquí 1 y 2 y por lo tanto
obtengo este vector que tengo aquí
perfecto este es mi vector am y ahora me
voy a fijar en director de director de
es el 03 por lo tanto no camino nada
hacia la derecha en la izquierda y
camino 3 hacia arriba aquí tengo el
vector ven muy bien ya que tengo a am y
ya que tenga ven cómo se va a ver tres
veces a menos dos veces ve es decir la
combinación lineal que tengo aquí abajo
tres veces am si recordamos un poco lo
que vimos en los vídeos pasados es hacer
este vector tres veces más grande por lo
tanto una dos tres veces más grande voy
a hacer a este vector y está entonces es
tres veces am y si yo tengo menos dos
veces ven y ojo aquí hay un signo de
menos por lo tanto a ver hay que voltear
lo primero para después ver quién es
menos 2
este de aquí sería menos ven y ahora que
tengo menos ve quién va a ser menos dos
veces ven este de hasta acá va a ser
menos dos veces ve y ya que tengo menos
dos veces ven ahora quién va a ser tres
menos dos veces ven lo que hay que hacer
es unir el punto final de tres veces am
con el punto inicial de menos dos veces
ven entonces esto me queda más o menos
así y justo me da el resultado que yo
quería mi resultado es el 30 es decir
que esta combinación lineal me da como
resultado el vector 30 que es este que
tengo aquí este vector de azul es tres
veces a menos dos veces ven y si te das
cuenta medio de resultado un nuevo
vector este vector que tengo aquí pero
ahora qué pasa si yo tomo no sé 1.5 a en
lugar de tres veces am pues tendría a
este nuevo vector y después tengo que
hacer dos veces ve para abajo y me
quedaría este nuevo de aquí y por lo
tanto si yo sumo 1.5 a que es otra
combinación lineal menos dos veces b me
va a quedar un nuevo vector este vector
que estoy tomando aquí aquí tenemos a
nuestro
víctor y ahora la pregunta es qué pasa
si yo me tomo el conjunto de todas las
combinaciones lineales de estos dos
vectores es decir imagínense que yo me
tomo un conjunto con todos los posibles
resultados de multiplicar al vector a
por una constante ya esto sumarle el
vector b x otra constante stoner de 2
que me quedaría tanto matemáticamente
como visto de forma gráfica y esa es la
pregunta tras la probó pero vamos a
intentar hacerlo primero de una forma
mental imagínate que yo agarro cualquier
escalar multiplicando mi vector a mí y
me da este de aquí
supongamos y después a esto le agrego
cualquier otro escalar multiplicando
bien pero ves solamente va hacia arriba
o hacia abajo por lo tanto podría
obtener esta línea que va hacia arriba o
esta línea que va hacia abajo esto es si
estoy multiplicando a por un escalar si
lo multiplicó por otro escalar un poco
más grande entonces me daría esta línea
que tengo aquí porque ves solamente va
de arriba hacia abajo y se multiplicó a
por un escalar negativo entonces me
daría esta línea que tengo aquí y así
todo hacia abajo y si es una escalar
mucho más pequeño que el inicial
entonces me daría esta línea recta que
tengo aquí por lo tanto te estás dando
cuenta que yo puedo generar todo el
plano con estos dos vectores ya eso es a
lo que se le conoce como el espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores entonces cómo escribirlo aquí
el espacio vectorial generado por estos
dos vectores a y b pues me dan todo el
plano es decir r2 el espacio generado
por ahí b en este caso fue r 2 porque
date cuenta que cualquier punto de r2 lo
puedo encontrar como una combinación
lineal de estos dos vectores si hacemos
una combinación de ellos pueden llegar a
cualquier punto del plano a cualquier
punto que a mí se me ocurra y bueno
ahora lo que se me ocurre preguntarte es
qué pasa si tenemos otros dos vectores
también nos van a generar el plano
cartesiano es decir todo r2 siempre el
espacio generado por dos vectores es r 2
pues a ver vamos a tomarnos al vector a
que es el vector 2 2 y si lo pongo en su
posición estándar me va a dar este
vector que tengo aquí este es mi vector
am y entonces también me tengo que tomar
a otro
y ahora me voy a tomar al vector b el
cual va a ser el menos 2 2 este va a ser
mi vector b y bueno si yo encuentro una
combinación lineal de a idv si te das
cuenta todas las combinaciones lineales
tanto de a cómo debe están sobre esta
recta que voy a dibujar aquí porque si
yo a am a vélez sumó a v me van a
generar esta línea recta enorme que yo
tengo aquí porque tanto a como b son
vectores q lineales es decir como a y b
están sobre una misma recta entonces el
espacio generado por el vector a y el
vector de quién crees que va a ser pues
esta recta claro está y es que fíjate si
yo agarro un vector cualquiera aquí en
r2 supongamos este por más que yo busque
una combinación lineal de ay debe nunca
voy a poder generar este vector sep
porque cualquier combinación de ahí debe
no puede salir de esta línea recta que
yo tengo aquí no hay forma de acomodar
los que me den un vector sé como éste
que estoy dibujando aquí por lo tanto el
espacio generado en esta ocasión por el
vector a y el vector b va a ser ni más
ni menos por el vector
y el vector ven es esta recta que tengo
aquí exactamente y entonces te das
cuenta que no todo par de vectores
generan el plano cartesiano en este caso
hay beheshti generado en alrededores
pero qué tal si yo agarro otro otro
vector es más vamos a agarrar en esta
ocasión en lugar de un par de vectores
solamente a un vector no voy a tomar el
espacio vectorial generado por el vector
cero
el espacio vectorial generado por el
vector cero pues es ni más ni menos que
el vector cero mismo porque si tú
agarras el vector cero que recuerda que
es a que el vector cuyas componentes son
0 y 0 y lo multiplicas por cualquier
constante siempre te va a dar 0 y 0
porque cualquier constante por 0 es cero
y cualquier constante por cero es cero
por lo tanto el espacio vectorial
generado solamente por el vector cero me
da el vector cero y qué pasa si yo tomo
cualquier otro vector ya este otro
vector yo le tomo el espacio vectorial
generado es decir me voy a tomar el
espacio vector ya generador de un solo
vector es más aquí tengo a am y por lo
tanto me voy a fijar a quién está a que
yo tenía que arriban y voy a generar el
espacio vectorial
este mismo vector con este único vector
el espacio vectorial generado por este
vector a pues quién va a ser pues son
todos los vectores que tienen la forma
una constante por up y si recuerdas en
los primeros vídeos que yo hice acerca
de vectores nosotros definimos que una
constante multiplicada por un vector te
da una línea recta por lo tanto el
espacio vectorial generado por una
constante por am es lo mismo que el
espacio vectorial que generábamos con
puros vectores con lineales lo cual es
una recta seria esta recta que estoy
dibujando aquí toda esta recta va a ser
mi espacio vectorial generado por
solamente un vector por lo tanto al
menos hasta aquí vemos que un vector es
su espacio generado es una línea recta
que el espacio generado por el vector
cero es el vector cero y que el espacio
generado por dos vectores no siempre es
r 2 pero en este caso me salió que seré
2 y bueno aquí te quiero poner a los dos
vectores que más usualmente generan r 2
en casi todos los libros de textos de
tomás a estos dos vectores al vector y
el vector j los cuales generan r 2 el
vector y es el vector
10 estos son los vectores de ley que van
a generar t a todo tu plano cartesiano y
así que vamos a dibujar lo tenemos crear
solamente un paso hacia la derecha y
bueno el otro vector es el vector j que
es el vector 01 así que también lo voy a
poner en su posición estándar con otro
color y va a ser un vector que solamente
tenemos que dar un paso hacia arriba y
bueno estos vectores son unos vectores
que generan todo el valor cristiano y se
utilizan mucho en física el espacio
vectorial que generan estos dos vectores
es todo r2 y esto es porque cualquier
vector que yo ponga en el plano
cartesiano lo podemos obtener como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
y de hecho se conoce que estos dos
vectores son una base de r2 pero ya con
más calma entraré a la definición de
base y ahorita no me voy a meter en ese
problema solamente quédense con que
estos vectores canónicos tienen como
espacio vectorial generado a todo el
plano r 2 y bueno ahora me voy a
regresar otra vez a pensar en los
vectores am y b pero bueno creo que
estaría muy bien que pusiéramos la
definición formal de
es un espacio vectorial generado por
varios vectores entonces el espacio
vectorial generado por los vectores b1
b2 b3 todos esos hasta bn quien va a ser
pues es un conjunto de vectores un
conjunto de vectores de la forma que uno
por b1 c2 por b 2 más de 3 por b 3 +
etcétera etcétera etcétera más cn por bn
tal vez que todos los c es decir todas
las constantes existen en los números
reales son miembros de los números
reales y para que se vale esto bueno
para y desde uno hasta n line lo máximo
que puede valer es n y lo mínimo que
puede valer es 1 y esta es la definición
del espacio vectorial generado por los
vectores b1 b2 b3 b4 hasta bn y ya con
esto tenemos una definición formal de
qué pasa con un espacio vectorial
generado por unos vectores si te das
cuenta solamente es tomar la combinación
lineal de todos los vectores y variar
todas las constantes que se puedan para
ver qué obtenemos de las combinaciones
lineales de estos
y ver qué conjunto se forma y bueno esta
definición ya está muy general porque
está hablando de n vectores y en este
caso recuerda que los vectores aire
generaban el espacio vectorial que era
igual a r2 o dicho de otra manera a ive
generaban todo el plano cartesiano y
suena muy padre pero realmente esto será
cierto es decir si yo me tomo un vector
cualquiera realmente este vector lo
puedo ver como una combinación lineal de
los lectores
ahí ve pues vamos a ver si eso es cierto
me voy a tomar un vector cualquiera en
r2 y es el vector le voy a llamar el
vector x así que darle un poco de
espacio recuerda que es el vector 1 2 y
b es el vector 03 déjame escribir lo que
antes de que se me olvide el vector a es
el vector 1 2 y el vector b es el vector
cuyas componentes son el 0 y 3 y bueno
yo me voy a tomar cualquier otro vector
que pueda vivir en r2 y como lo voy a
ver de forma general voy a tomar un
vector x que es el vector x 1 x 2 y
ahora me pregunta es este vector x 1
2 lo podemos escribir como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
esto qué quiere decir que si yo
multiplico una constante 1 por el vector
a y le sumó una constante de 2 que
multiplica el vector de me tienen que
dar el vector x esto será cierto para
cualquier equis que yo me tome para
cualquier vector x que yo me tomé pues
bueno vamos a ver qué es que yo tenga
hace 1 x ha puesto quiere decir que
tengo una constante 1 que va a
multiplicar al vector 12 ya esto tengo
que agregarle c 2 que va a multiplicar
al vector 0 3 y esto tiene que ser igual
al vector x 1 x 2 tengo una constante
según lo que multiplica al vector 1 2 y
después tengo una constante 2 que
multiplica al vector b pero el vector b
es el vector 0 3 y eso tiene que ser
igual al vector x 1 x 2 perfecto
entonces esto tiene que ser igual al
vector x1 y x2 y bueno esto qué quiere
decir que si yo multiplico c1 déjeme
escribirlo de una vez de uno por uno me
quedase 11 segundos + 0 por 0 2 pues
tengo que hacer o bsc 2 esto es lo mismo
que
esto es lo que yo quisiera que pasara y
bueno esto es cuando pensamos en la
componente x ya tengo una ecuación pero
ahora qué pasa si pienso en la
componente y me quedaría que dos veces
uno más tres veces eeuu no perdona que
puse c2 a c1 dos veces se 13 veces c2c 2
por 3 es tres veces 2 tiene que ser
igual a x2 a la componente del vector x
y ahora me pregunta es es cierto que
esto se cumple para algún c1 y c2 en los
números reales y bueno ya tengo un
sistema de ecuaciones voy a intentar
resolverlo para ver si llego a algo en
primera parte tengo cero veces 2 por lo
tanto esto se cancelaría y bueno me
queda que 1 c 1 es igual de x 1 y qué
les parece si la primera ecuación la
multiplicó por menos 2 para ponerle aquí
abajo me quedaría menos dos veces eeuu
no estoy tomando menos dos veces la
ecuación 1 para que pueda cancelarla con
la ecuación de abajo más 0 es igual a
menos 2 veces x 1 y dos veces uno menos
dos veces ese uno se van estoy
utilizando el método de suma y resta y
simple sencillamente me quedan que tres
veces de 2
es igual a quien tres veces dos es igual
a x2 menos 2 veces x 1
y bueno si yo paso el 3 dividiendo ya
voy a obtener un valor para este 2 2 es
igual a un tercio de x2 menos 2 veces x
1 y si te das cuenta aquí puse un tercio
porque pase el 3 dividiendo del otro
lado y bueno ya cuando tengo el valor
para este 2 y el valor para ese 1 pues
es muy fácil sacarlo de la primera
ecuación si te das cuenta tengo una vez
sé 10 es igual de x 1 ya que obtengo que
ese uno tiene que ser igual x 1 y por lo
tanto ya tengo dos valores que ese 2
tiene que ser un tercio de todo esto y
segundo tiene que ser igual a x1 por lo
tanto dado cualquier vector en este
plano cartesiano en todo el de dos cuyas
componentes sean x1 y x2 yo ya obtengo
dos constantes de las cuales al
multiplicar las por el vector ahí el
multiplicarlos por el vector b
esta combinación lineal me van a dar
este vector x y bueno estaría muy bien
probar estas nuevas igualdades para se
unen para este 2 con cualquier vector
que se me ocurra voy a tomar un vector
en el espacio r 2 y que se me ocurra
el vector 22 y voy a ver si realmente
con estas fórmulas y usando un poco de
álgebra de vectores puedo obtener este
vector llamado 22 este vector 2 2 el
vector x y bueno como puedo encontrar yo
una combinación lineal de ahí de vegetal
que me del vector 22 entonces me
quedaría que sea uno tiene que ser igual
a x1 por lo tanto hace algunos igualados
y c2 tiene que ser igual a un tercio de
x2 menos x1 es decir de 0 2 menos 20 y
por lo tanto este 2 me queda 0 y aquí ya
me suena algo raro por aquí debe de
haber algún error porque si se 2 vale 0
aquí hay algo raro allá en contra el
error es que cuando yo escribí esta
parte de aquí no puse 2 veces x 1 era x
2 menos 2 veces x 1 y solamente puse una
vez x 1 por lo tanto que hay que
aumentar en un 2 y queda un tercio de x
2 - x 1 y ahora sí que me va a quedar de
2 tiene que ser igual a un tercio de x 2
menos 2 veces x 1 es decir un tercio de
x 2 x 2 es la componente en 10 del
vector al que quiero llegar es decir 2
menos 2 veces x 1
y dos veces la componente en x del
vector al cual quiero llegar que es 2 y
por lo tanto me queda un tercio que
multiplica a 2 menos 4 y esto es lo
mismo que menos dos tercios y perfecto
ya encontré c1 y c2 tal vez que es
cuando yo hago una combinación lineal
con c1 y c2 de ahí debe me tiene que dar
el vector 2-2 es decir dos veces a menos
dos tercios de b es igual al vector 2.2
o vamos a escribirlo sustituyendo a
yahvé dos veces el vector 12 menos dos
tercios del vector b que el vector 03
tiene que ser igual al vector 2-2 y esto
es cierto